two wizards trail miami with 6 43 to go  here  in the second bradley beal 14 points  back on the floor with abdia lopez back  in  the starting five out there here's beale  butler able to take it away and veal  commits the foul  that'll be the second foul against peel  and those two are doing a little  dance together brad didn't want to let  it go  look at brad i mean uh jimmy butler  jimmy butler still had one of the best  reactions when he said hello to you last  year in miami when you said man  i'm so happy for you a couple of  all-stars going at it right here two  eight players  and right there you see him smile  there's great there's great mutual  respect between these two guys right  here  you can see it's all